wouldn't wouldn't you say that the
divorce rate's going down because people
aren't getting married as much so think
about it right this let's talk about
divorce rate is by percentage so let's
do some numbers because you seem like a
very analytical girl logical girl let's
talk about some numbers thank you so if
the system of marriage is broken right
and a thousand people get married oh I
see the rate would still be I see okay
so let's do it for the people right
remember the the red pill argument is
the system is broken so that means
anyone who engages in this institution
whether or not you do it it's broken
it's not gonna work it's going to lead
to a 50 divorce rate so if a thousand
people get get married therefore it
should be 50 divorce rate but then if
900 people get divorced and 10 years
later instead of the thousand ten years
ago and now 900 people get married and
that divorce rate is 40 not 50 where was
before the question I must be asked is
these 100 people why did that number
change if the system was broken and
therefore whether it's a 1900 800 1200
1100 it should be the same thing but if
the number went down but then the
divorce rate decreased by a percentage
why did it go down who was not getting
married and how would it contributing to
the increase of divorce rates in the
past and that's why I said the numbers
will tell you a story and if you don't
know the full story you don't know how
the number is relevant to lots of
everyday people and that's what I'm
passionate about like you like I want to
keep on saying it a lot of the red pill
arguments are true a lot of them are
true mixed with a whole lot of lies and
and they and we have to be honest there
is an ideological event and there is a
for-profit bent for the ideologies but
if we're simply going to stop there and
not do a deep dive and analyzing the
study if we don't sit down and analyze
every single statistic number and
juxtaposed with the leading experts in
the world who are also studying these
things we don't have a full complete
message to share to men and women for
the benefit of society because to me if
we're genuinely saying that the red pill
message is the truth if it is indeed the
truth or attempt to convey the truth the
truth should only make Society better it
should only make men better it should
only make women better it should only
create a better world for us and so to
me when I see an ideology when I see a
practicality whatever the heck they're
calling you nowadays when I see a
worldview and I'm looking at it I'm
analyzing it and I'm understanding it
and I'm seeing all people who are
leaders in it and I've seen the
inconsistencies in what they saying what
they do I'm saying that there's a deeper
conversation with the numbers and a
deeper conversation with this type of
information that is not being discussed
and I'm glad we're doing it right now
um to me it's like if it goes from 50 to
40 who cares that's that's right don't
do that don't do that though because to
me people aren't getting together they
looked at the they get like getting
married rate is lower than it's ever
been so so it's like like to me it's
just like men are getting a bad deal
today and and and they're and they're
signing a contract where women are paid
to leave and take the kids and and to me
that's just especially in the UK like I
live in London like like girls like
their child support is literally
depended on how much you have the kids
so you're literally paid to take the
kids away okay so like to me it's just
like a bad deal and even even if you
sign a contract and it's a 40 versus 50
that's still not great you first and
foremost let's not be let's not be
deceptive right okay you cannot I'm not
if you understand statistics you cannot
say a 10 decrease in the likelihood of
something happening isn't a big deal if
there was a drug or if there was a
disease and we said you know what the
disease has a 50 percent let me finish
let me finish you told me not to cut two
of them I can cut you off okay because I
understand what you're trying to do
right now I was under the impression of
this would be a certain kind of
conversation but I'm getting what you're
doing right now so if you want to make
the conversation the way you want to
make this conversation it's no problem
so like I was saying the way I want to
make the colors like was saying like I
was saying if there was a disease and a
disease had a 50 percent fatality rate
and all of a sudden 10 years later even
if the the people the amount of people
with the disease went down by two
percent three percent four percent
whatever number you want to give but
then all of a sudden that disease has a
40 fatality rate the fatality rate went
down 10 or we ask ourselves yo how did
that happen no one says a 50 40 no big
deal so everything's the same thing no
you're gonna be like wow it's still high
then we would like it to be but it's a
lot better than the way it was before so
what can we learn from that what can we
improve on that how can we make that
better and so to me going back to the
ideology my biggest thing is I'm all
about how can we make the world a better
place and simply saying simply saying
that 50 40 that there's no big
difference it's it's deceptive full and
deceitful it is not communicating what's
really going on and so I think it's
really cool and it's I I kind of now a
lot of things are making more sense but
if we're gonna have a real conversation
about men and women in today's society
and married in today's society you we
have to get into specific details every
single point of the conversation and
understand the Nuance to each issue so
if you want to get into men getting a
bad deal in marriage we can talk about
that specific issue but I think
sometimes it's very easy to be able to
say in our Echo Chambers in our silos
and share these ideas without having
them flesh out that somebody can give us
some pushback but I just think like
you're missing the point like the point
is that the laws don't favor men today
like the point is is it 50 or 40 that's
not the point the point is that like
right now it's a contract that women are
paid to leave and so if if that's the
way the laws are set up I understand why
men are walking away like I understand
why they wouldn't push marriage so
here's the deal mm-hmm so let's let's
play your game I love to play your game
I'm not trying to
sorry okay I'm okay I'm playing I'm
having
fun good yeah yeah okay games is a word
okay guys we're having fun content we
have like we have people here we're
having a good day yeah don't take
anything okay yeah some of the peppers
might be too spicy we're just having no
I know I know go ahead so let's play
your game okay let's say the system is
all the way effed up yeah men are
getting screwed left and right what do
we do now
um I think you changed the laws like I
honestly actually I'd like to run for an
office someday I'd like to actually try
to change the laws I love what you just
said yeah I love what you just said my
question to you you're very smart when
you said we should change the laws yeah
how many people are getting into law how
many people are doing content to be able
to change the laws or versus how many
people are doing content simply
complaining about the laws in your
personal opinion all feelings no facts
shout out to Andrew Schultz what percent
of people are actually trying to change
the laws versus people complaining about
the loss all feelings no facts no
I don't know I've met a lot of men's
rights activists they actually have a
really have you ever talked to that
community at all yeah of course I've
seen the regular documentary
no not even that like they have whole
groups I don't know like that's that's
my you couldn't take you're a smart
woman you have no educated guess in the
world
um I don't think you're gonna like my
answer no no no no no I know I know I
know I feel like I feel like there
really aren't that many content creators
in the red pill space like I think it's
it's a generally small space on YouTube
so if I had to guess there's probably
more lawyers trying to change the laws
okay as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible